KIMBERLY.
THE MEDIA, LIBERALS, HILLARY
CLINTON PROUDLY PROCLAIMED SHE
WAS THE CANDIDATE FOR WOMEN.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BEING A ROLE MODEL TO MY
DAUGHTER AS WELL AS YOUNG WOMEN
BUILT ON THE PERSECUTION OF
WOMEN.
>> 22 YEARS AGO, HILLARY CLINTON
>> ONLY WAY WE WILL GET SIXISM
OUT OF POLITICS -- SEXISM OUT OF
POLITICS IS GET WOMEN NO
POLITICS.
>> A WOMAN IN WOMEN'S
EMPOWERMENT.
>> IF WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT
BUILDING A BIGGER, STRONGER
AMERICA WE NEED TO BE SEAR RUSE
ABOUT NEWER TOURING OUR GIRLS.
>> COPS, FIRST RESPONDERS,
HEALTHCARE AND GIRLS AROUND THE
WORLD.
>> HILLARY DEVOTED HER WHOLE
LIFE TO MAKING SURE WOMEN AND
CHILDREN HAVE AN EVEN SHOT.
>> TO ALL THE WOMEN AND
ESPECIALLY THE YOUNG WOMEN WHO
PUT THEIR FAITH IN THIS CAMPAIGN
AND IN ME, I WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT NOTHING HAS MADE ME PROUDER
THAN TO BE YOUR CHAMPION.
>> NOW, A STUNNING REPORT CLAIMS
CLINTON KEPT THE SENIOR ADVISOR
ON HER 2008 PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN EVEN AFTER LEARNING OF
SEXUAL MARCH RASMENT ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST HIM.
ACCORDING TO THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" A 30-YEAR-OLD FEMALE
STAFFER ACCUSED BUSH STRIELDER
OF HARASSING HER.
REPORTEDLY ORDERED TO UNDERGO
COUNSELING AND THE CAMPAIGN
DOCKED HIS WAY.
THE YOUNG WOMAN WAS MOVED TO A
NEW JOB.
IMMUNE TO THE ACCUSATIONS.
AND THESE ALLEGATIONS WRITTEN IN
THE "NEW YORK TIMES," FINALLY
REACH UP INTO HILLARY CLINTON'S
CAMPAIGN.
>> ONLY A MATTER OF TIME, RIGHT,
THIS HAS BEEN SOMETHING THAT SHE
HAS BEEN REALLY TRYING TO OWN
THE MAT FORM, TO SAY SHE IS FOR
WOMEN, SHE IS FOR CHILDREN,
SHE'S FOR YOUNG GIRLS FOR THEIR
AREN'T VICTIMIZED.
YOU SEE A SITUATION LIKE THIS,
CONTINUING TO ALLOW THIS
ENABLING BEHAVIOR.
WE SAW WITH IT HER RELATIONSHIP
WITH HER, YOU KNOW, HUSBAND.
AND TRYING TO ATTACK THE VICTIMS
THERE, TRYING TO COVER UP
MISDEEDS.
IF YOU REALLY LOOK AT THE
HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE IN TERMS
OF WHAT SHE SAID AND HOW SHE'S
CONDUCTED HERSELF SHE ISN'T A
CHAMPION OF WOMEN AND YOUNG
GIRLS.
>> YOU REALLY COULDN'T ASK FOUR
A STORY THAT -- FOR A STORY THAT
WAS BETTER AT PUTTING TOGETHER
HOLLYWOOD AND THEIR SITUATION
AND THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN, WHICH
IT GOES TO SHOW YOU, TO YOUR
EARLIER POINT, SHE IS STORIES
ARE EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
EMBARRASSMENTS.
HIT EVERY POLITICAL STRIPE.
YOU MIGHT SAY HAH, I KNEW IT.
THEN IT COMES BACK AND HITS YOUR
KEY.
YOU CAN'T LOOK AT IT AS TEAM
SPORT.
ALSO, TALK ABOUT BEING
COMPROMISED.
THESE STORIES COMPROMISE YOU.
WHAT COULD SHE DO ABOUT THIS
WHO'S DONE 1/10 OF 1% OF WHAT
HER HUSBAND HAS DONE WHO SHE IS
COMPROMISED.
SHE SHOULD KNOW SEXISM, SHE HAD
A FIRST HAND FRONT LOW SEAT OF
AN OLYMPIC ATHLETE IN SEXUAL
HARASSMENT, IN HER HUSBAND.
LOOK AT THIS.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> JUAN, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
HAPPENED TO 24 YOUNG WOMAN, SHE
DOESN'T REVEAL HER NAME IN THE
STORY, INSTEAD OF DEALING WITH
HIM AND FIRING HIM, SHE HAD TO
MOVE TO ANOTHER JOB.
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK THAT'S
TRUE.
FROM WHAT I READ, HE WAS PUT
INTO COUNSELING, AND HE HAD HIS
PAY DOCKED, AS I UNDERSTAND IT.
SO ESSENTIALLY, AT THAT POINT,
HE WAS SUSPENDED.
BUT THE PROBLEM --
>> DIDN'T SAY SUSPENDED.
>> NO, SHE GOT A DIFFERENT JOB.
>> SHE GOT MOVED BUT THEY
>> MY POINT WAS THAT, MIGHT BE A
CULTURAL SHIFT GOING FORWARD FOR
WOMEN WHO MAKE ACCUSATIONS,
INSTEAD OF MOVING THEM JUST TO
ANOTHER JOB, SO THEY DON'T HAVE
TO DEAL WITH THE GUY ANY MORE,
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENED IN 2008,
SHE GOT MOVED.
>> WELL I THINK THERE SHAUBD
PROCESS.
-- SHOULD BE A PROCESS.
WE TALK ABOUT IDEA THAT NOT
EVERYTHING IS HARVEY WEINSTEIN.
THERE SHOULD BE A PROSES, THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO HEAR WHAT HE
HAS TO SAY IN HIS OWN DEFENSE.
OPPORTUNITY FOR CONSERVATIVES TO
SECURE HER AS A PRIME EXAMPLE OF
LIBERAL HYPOCRISY.
IF THAT'S WHAT THE POINT IS
HERE, I THINK YOU KNOW WHAT?
CONSERVATIVES, YOU WIN THIS ONE.
[LAUGHING]
I WILL SAY IT'S NOT FEAR, SOME
OF MY COLLEAGUES SAY HILLARY
CLINTON HAD TO PUT UP BILL
CLINTON AND THEREFORE EXCUSES.
THAT'S NOT WHAT HAPPENED.
AND I WILL SAY MOST AMERICAN
WOMEN TRYING TO KEEP THEIR
MARRIAGES AND FAMILIES TOGETHER
WILL PUT UP A WHOLE LOT OF
NONSENSE.
SO, YOU KNOW, WHAT I DON'T THINK
THAT'S FAIR.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, IF YOU WANT
TO DELIGHT IN THIS STORY
XWOESHGS FOR IT.
>> I DON'T THINK ANYONE IS
DELIGHTING.
>> WELL THAT'S WHY WE'RE DOING
THIS STORY.
>> I THINK FROM THE DEMOCRATS'
POINT OF VIEW THE CONTRARY STORY
TODAY HAS TO DO WITH STEVE WYNN,
AND THE VEGAS MAG NATE, WHO IS
IN POWER AS THE FINANCE CHAIR OF
THE RNC.
>> THAT STORY IN THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL BROKE WITHIN THE SAME
HOUR OF THIS STORY IN THE
NEW YORK TIMES.
REPUBLICAN POLITICS, THIS
HAPPENS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE.
HILLARY HAS ALWAYS BEEN FOR ONE
THING, HILLARY CLINTON.
HER CAMPAIGN MANAGER RECOMMENDED
THAT THIS GUY BE FIRED.
THIS GUY IS NOT JUST AN ADVISOR,
HE WAS THE FAITH ADVISOR.
>> SPIRITUAL ADVISOR.
AT ONE POINT, ALL HAVE FALLEN
AND FALLEN SHORT OF THE GLORY OF
GOD.
EVERYONE SINS.
BUT IF YOU ARE THE FAITH ADVISOR
AND ACCUSED OF KISSING PEOPLE
AND SUGGESTIVE E-MAILS DURING
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT MAYBE
THE STANDARD SHOULD BE HIGHER
FOR YOU.
SHE GETS MOVED AND SHE GETS
TRAINING AND SOME COUNSELING.
BUT PUT BACK IN HIS POSITION.
IS WARRIOR TO BE BELIEVED?
ONLY WHEN IT'S SOME ONE ELSE'S
BUT IT IS IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT
SHE RAN HER CAMPAIGN ON BEING A
CHAMPION OF WOMEN.
HISTORY IS RIDDLED WITH WOMEN --
>> AT THE TO.
SHOW, PETE, THE MONTAGE, I WAS
WAITING FOR HER TO SAY ANY TIME
A WOMAN SAYS SOMETHING THEN THE
GUY HAS TO BE THROWN OUT.
WELL, SHE DIDN'T DO THAT.
AND INSPIRED WOMEN, ESPECIALLY
YOUNG WOMEN AND SHE WAS A ROLE
MODEL.
>> EVERY SURVIVOROR OF SEXUAL
>> EXCEPT FOR JUANITA BRODERICK.
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN THERE.
>> WHAT SHE DID PALES IN
COMPARISON TO THE THINGS THAT
HAPPENED BEFORE AND HOW SHE
TREATED PEOPLE THAT HAD ACCUSED
VALUES NETWORK?
>> VERY PROMINENT ORGANIZATION.
>> SOUNDS LINE ONE OF THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE IN A MADE
FOR TV MOVIE.
HE WAS DOING THE WRONG KIND OF
PRAYING.
>> NOT EVERYONE IS A -- PERVERTS
COMMIT THESE PROBLEMS
EVERYWHERE.
IT'S NOT JUST MOVIE PRODUCERS.
>> KIMBERLY, GOING FORWARD, NOT
GOING TO TURN THE PAGE AND GO
BACKWARDS, NOT GOINPINDUST
ICE BEEN EVERYWHERE.
>> WE'RE SEEING THAT
EVOLUTION -- HAS BEEN SWIFT AND
IMMEDIATE.
WHAT DOES HILLARY CLINTON DO
GOING FORWARD, IS SHE GOING TO
TRY TO CAPTURE THE MANTLE HERE
AND ACKNOWLEDGE SOME WRONGDOING
OR MISTAKES AND HOW SHE HANDLED
THINGS IN THE PAST?
TO TRY AND RESTORE CREDIBILITY.
THAT'S THE POINT, SHE HAS, BEEN
THE ONE THAT POSITIONED HERSELF
AS SORT OF THE FACE OF THIS
MOVEMENT AND BEING SUPPORTIVE OF
COULD WOMEN.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO CAMPAIGN, WHO
SHOULD BE CONSISTENT.
>> PART OF THE WAY SHE LOST.
THEY'RE MANUFACTURED ISH EWING
OR BASED ON THE HISTORY THAT
DOESN'T COMFORT WITH THOSE
CONDITIONS.
PEOPLE SAW THROUGH THAT.
CANDIDATE TRUMP WASN'T PERFECT
ON THOSE ISSUES THEY FORGIVE HIM
FOR CANDOR AND AUTHENTICITY AS
OPPOSED TO MASKING OVER.
>> I WAS FOLLOWING YOU UNTIL
GRABBING A WOMAN IN THAT WAY IS
EXCUSABLE BUT NOT --
>> HE CAME OUT --
>> NOT GOING THROUGH A LEGAL
PROCESS WHERE YOU SAY IT'S GOOD
FOR YOUR COMPANY, IT'S OKAY TO
EXCUSE DONALD TRUMP AND NOW THE
PORN STAR BUT NOT HILLARY?
>> LOCKER ROOM TALK IS
DIFFERENT --
>> LOCKER ROOM TALK?
>> HOW HE EXPLAINED IT.
>> HE SAID THAT HE ASSAULTED
WOMEN, THAT'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> WELL, HE NEVER SAID THAT.
>> ARE WE GOING TO PARSE THE
WORDS?
>> I THINK WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO.
IT, WAS THAT HE WAS TALKING
>> HE SAID "I".
>> HE SAID "YOU."
I THINK HE SAID YOU.
THIS IS THE PROBLEM WITH THIS,
WHEN YOU GO DOWN THERE ROAD AND
TALK ABOUT THIS CRAP.
>> THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT THE
PORN STAR.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S A
QUESTION.
AT ONE POINT, YOU SAY, OH --
>> ARE YOU SEX SHAMING HER?
>> WHO?
>> BECAUSE SHE'S A PORN STAR?
S THAT BOTHER YOU?